first of all this movie lives up to its
title cube this movie has the most epic
fistfight of all time
you'd think movie fistfight okay there's
gonna be a fist fight this thing is I
think the biggest fist fight that's ever
occurred on film ever occurred you know
we we fought more than rocky in this
movie cuz yeah the fight went eight days
you know and we got bumps and bruises
Charlie keeps telling me that I slammed
them into a bust
I know honey I slammed you to the bus
times it really so you were doing a
scene where he's supposed to sling you
in the bus now it's called acting so you
don't really not really supposed to slam
him into the barber cube is a very
committed actor and now my arm hurts
forever that's not a medical condition
your arm hurts so you guys really went
for it I'm just curious I'm just gonna
ask you some personal stories Tracy did
you ever get into a fistfight and you're
like yeah she whupped my ass big murders
it was the third grade what was my name
was big murders and it was the birthday
I didn't know how to tell her I liked us
all punching her home yeah it was on and
poppin after that and she knocked me out
cuz she had the big Sonny Liston hands
[Laughter]
yeah wait so how old was this girl with
the Sonny Liston hands no shoes about
she was 250 then but that was it but no
one it's not like you if you if you got
into a fight or something could you do
anyone yet you've got fights with epic
my face I had a corner man at a cut man
Ernie [ __ ] jr. who is Joe Frazier's
corner man
whose pick whatever contracts disputed
aren't you supposed to go and get like
in my day if you were getting into a
fight you would go and get like oh I'll
get my older brother he'll take care of
it yeah I couldn't do that my brother
was crippled oh is that for real yes for
real yeah so you know sometimes the
bullies and the schoolyards could be me
yeah so I had to learn how to be funny
to keep him about mom behind either that
I'll make them hot dogs every day after
[Applause]
hot dogs with some red onions and
pop-tarts that was old comedy haven't
you learned not to ask
you